I think you know hyperspace and the Star
Wars Universe think again because Ahsoka
is changing everything we know about the
concept of light speed travel following
an action-packed and fan service-built
fifth installment Ahsoka has returned to
Disney plus once more this episode
appropriately titled part 6 Far Far Away
places to focus on Sabine Wren who has
traveled to a new Galaxy alongside the
villainous Morgan ellsbeth Valen skull
and shin haughty while the villains meet
with grand Admiral thrawn Sabine embarks
on a search for her long-lost friend
Ezra Bridger on an unfamiliar world at
the same time Ahsoka Tano and hu Yang
travel inside the mouth of a pergil
venturing through hyperspace to rescue
Sabine and stop thrawn's Sinister plan
we only see a brief scene of the two
Heroes early in the episode though it
does raise one big question as the
pergols Embark on their Voyage to a new
Galaxy hyperspace takes on a very
different appearance to what Star Wars
fans might know rather than its usual
swirling white blue look the simu tunnel
the pergil Pod moves through is streaky
and multicolored featuring green orange
and indigo Hues while this is most
likely how the minds behind the Soco
wanted to convey to viewers that the per
girls are traveling to a different
galaxy there could be more to this new
hyperspace look
pergola among the most fascinating
creatures in the Star Wars universe and
not just because of their look or
backstory rather it's their unique
biology that makes them so interesting
these massive space-faring whales
breathe in a gas called klauson 36 which
their bodies take in and turn into hyper
matter fuel when sufficiently fueled up
their tentacles will glow and they'll
make the jump to hyperspace venturing
from Galaxy to Galaxy at their Leisure
until they need to take in more gas once
again everyone else in the Star Wars
Galaxy can only jump through hyperspace
using a ship with an operational
hyperdrive in this case their clouds on
36 based fuel is refined by other means
and certainly not inside the body of a
pergal thus You could argue that the
pergale simu tunnel on Ahsoka looks
different than the one previously seen
in Star Wars because it's Unique to the
way in which the per Guild travel
perhaps the way they synthesize klauson
36 inside their bodies results in
hyperspace looking different than it
would if you use synthetic hyperfuel of
course for fans who are familiar with
Star Wars Rebels it won't be anything
new to experience a more colorful form
of hyperspace travel even without the
presence of per girls the series depicts
multicolored tunnel roles on multiple
occasions for example in the season 1
episode Gathering forces the ghost
accidentally jumps into hyperspace
courtesy of a rhodian agent named sibo
after an imperial tracker is placed on
the ship's auxiliary vessel the Phantom
Ezra Bridger and Kanan jarras concoct a
plan to detach it during a hyperspace
jump the risky move pays off but not
without a bumpy and very vibrant fall
first in The Following Season Rebels
fans witnessed a similar sight during
the events of stealth strike traveling
through hyperspace in a Blockade Runner
Ezra and Commander Sato are confronted
by a dangerous Imperial weapon an
interdictor-class Star Destroyer the
experimental ship is capable of pulling
other ships out of hyperspace something
it does with ease to the hero Zone
vessel as they lose control of their
ship the blues and whites of hyperspace
are replaced by streaks of red yellow
and violet of course eagle-eyed fans
might have noticed that the villain's
hyperspace journey in episode 6 was
nearly as colorful as that taken by the
pergil this could mean that a vibrant
simu tunnel is merely a quirk of this
new Galaxy or that the eye of Scion
somehow utilizes the pergol's abilities
to travel into the unknown all of this
have space confusion just goes to show
that Star Wars space travel is far from
an exact science maybe someday a project
will come along that better explains the
ins and outs of hyperspace but for now
all we can do is speculate on the truth
behind its many colors
foreign